[Musique]
aller à la rencontre de l'autre au delà
de la barrière de la langue
dan ramène photographe spécialisé dans
les portraits le corps humain à explorer
la ville de querétaro au mexique pendant
un mois
un voyage qui a donné lieu à may hamm au
une exposition visible aux prises ma
elancourt on est invités oui avec avec
dan
ah non pas forcément découvrir la ville
de querétaro puisque c'est pas forcément
l'objet de l'exposition mais plutôt à
rentrer en contact à être avec l'autre à
découvrir toutes ces personnes en
résidence depuis deux ans sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
dan ramène a choisi de mettre en avant
27 photographies en noir et blanc des
personnes présentées dans leur contexte
de vie ou dans leurs contextes de
travail
ce n'est pas une photographie
instantanée lui il parle de moments
année dans la mesure où il a passé pas
mal de temps à discuter avec les gens
lors il parle très peu espagnol
donc il avait un petit panneau pour
indiquer sa démarche artistique
et puis avec voilà des petits bouts des
ongles est des petits gestes etc
l'exposition est complétée par deux
diaporamas en noir et blanc et en
couleur une sorte de huf à cette session
d'exploration
[Musique]